il y a deux tendances très négatives à
l'échelle mondiale une première tendance
très négative qui est la tendance
démographique qui dans la plupart dans
les pays du monde où la démographie est
croissante va entraîner presque
inévitablement
ce que j'appelle une dictature de
dictature de l'ignorance en Afrique en
Inde au Mexique au Brésil même en Chine
vous avez
entre 60 et 100 élèves par classe avec
des enseignants qui sont pas du tout au
niveau
donc c'est un éducation est une
mascarade un mythe ce n'est pas vrai on
enseigne pas
et quand on pense que comme vous le
savez la démographie indienne mexicaine
ou africaine va continuer à être
explosive on y arrivera pas
sauf à consacrer des moyens que dont on
ne doit pas nous ils vont venir donc on
se prépare un avenir africain indien etc
d'ignorance qui sera remplacée soit par
rien soit par
l'exclusion des filles pour commencer
soit un enseignement religieux qui a
déjà commencé très largement à prendre
la place et qui d'ailleurs le fait d'une
façon très brutale comme on le voit en
particulier dans certaines régions de
l'Inde et au Nigeria où c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très très systématique
donc là on a une bombe à retardement de
l'ignorance
qui est extrêmement général la deuxième
barbarie cette première c'est la
barbarie de l'ignorance la deuxième
c'est la barbarie technologique
qui et je reviendrai sur les aspects
très positifs de la technologie tout à
l'heure et d'entrer d'entraîner dans les
autres pays sur tout
un discrédit de l'ancien éducatif les
élèves savent mieux par ce qu'ils
apprennent sur les réseaux sociaux ou
ailleurs
donc ça fait un discrédit de l'école
ensuite comme vous l'avez dit
ça crée un déficit d'attention qui n'est
pas seulement qui n'est pas spécialement
lié au fait que la tension est plus
courte en effet elle est plus courte
mais qu'il y ait au fait surtout
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une invasion très
jeune des esprits par les jeux vidéo et
par tout cela qui fait que aujourd'hui
et dans certaines régions du monde en
particulier au Canada en Grande-Bretagne
et en France aussi mais dans son corps
moins fortes en France le temps occupé
par les jeux vidéo
atteint pas tout à fait mais presque le
temps consacré à l'école on passe des
enfants passe plus de temps devant les
jeux vidéo et les réseaux sociaux
particuliers TikTok mais pas seulement
TikTok que que à l'école
donc voilà on a là un basculement de
système qui est évidemment
extraordinairement destructif du
processus éducatif si on ajoute à ça que
ça crée
un processus de solitude de de
refus de la vie collective on a la
risque énorme de voir
non seulement les écoles discréditées
par le fait que on y va on y va d'une
façon contrat dépenser on y apprend plus
ce qu'on apprend ailleurs mais aussi
détournement de la capacité
d'apprentissage sur des choses futiles
et sans intérêt